I thought a good place to start really
would be with the notion of the long
view how does columbia look over time
and really start with you Susan you
started several decades ago how has the
University I think it was right after
the Dutch bought Manhattan how has a
university changed since you first
arrived I know I i finally have arrived
at that moment where i can no longer
hide my age and I did take out of my bio
where it said 35 years of alumni
relations and development experience I
thought out you know just she's a lot of
experience just say a lot of experience
for me I think most of you know for me
there wasn't one arrival time at
Columbia there really had been three
arrival times and as I was thinking as
we were talking about this panel and we
were talking about a little bit of
retrospective I realized for me it was
nineteen sixty-eight 1982 and 2002 and
in a way they were three different
Columbia's that I joined 1968 September
I arrived GS student working full-time
at the university within the first year
for various just you know sometimes
you're lucky and in the right place at
the right time I ended up as a junior
secretary in the president's office by
1974 I had moved into the development
office and I think what was so different
then obviously it was such a cataclysmic
time for Columbia and I was part of that
for me of course not being a senior
administrator it was an incredibly
stimulating and remarkable time to be at
Columbia remarkable time to be coming of
age I didn't expect to have a
traditional college experience and so I
wasn't disappointed not to have one you
know I think if you talk to all of us
who were here then people either thought
it was just an amazing moment in history
to be part of or they were disappointed
that they didn't have kind of for
traditional years and I was in the
unbelievable opportunity to see society
changing you know and so glad
that I wasn't going through this as the
executive vice president for development
and alumni relations okay because I've
thought a lot back about what could
Columbia have done differently at that
point all of alumni and development even
by the mid 70s was in a couple of sweets
of offices on the third floor of low
library so for alumni relations and
development you know it even though it
was going into 68 was a pretty
up-to-date model for its moment it was
still pretty small when I came back in
nineteen eighty-two to this was a time
when Mike sovereign was president and
we'd come through the tough 1970s and
there really was a commitment to rebuild
the development program and we were
having a university-wide campaign the
first since the late 60s and I came back
to work on that and it by that point we
had moved off campus and we were in
Teachers College space and i have to say
at that point because the focus was
purely on development there was a real
neglect of the alumni relations aspect
of columbia and then coming back in 2002
with Lee Bollinger sharing this view
that we had really missed the boat at
Columbia and not having closer
connections in more engagement of the
Alumni in the University and one theory
about that you know as I was thinking
even this morning in 1968 275 my first
time here I think alumni there was this
perception that all alumni had turned
against the university because of the
late sixties troubles now we would know
better now we would know do a national
global tour take the president
everywhere talk to everybody let
everybody scream and gnash their teeth
at how upset they were with Columbia get
it all out then it was stick heads in
the sand ignore you know shut the
campaign down don't do alumni relations
because there's no way you're going to
get people connected of course it was a
self-fulfilling prophecy in a way now I
realize we would do this in a very
different way wouldn't necessarily be a
fun thing to do but but we would not
let the alumni connections easily go
away so it has been fascinating to kind
of come back to Columbia three different
points in time and sort of watch the
evolution of the university clearly for
me this is the most exciting time I
think of all those three times the
university as a whole has the most
positive forward-looking sense of a
university on the move even during this
last hard year so it's fantastic to be
here to watch this one of the privileges
of being moderators you can add whatever
you want between questions I I think
that a one aspect of what Susan said
really deserves amplification as
recently as 2002 when I arrived as I
spoke to people in the community the
columbia university community broadly
defined there was still this sense
actually several people said to me if we
keep our heads down no one will shoot it
off and what's remarkable to me over the
last six eight ten years eight years now
is that that sense of insecurity or
inferiority or battles those battle
scars are gone and we'll talk more about
manhattanville shortly but when the City
Council New York City Council voted to
approve the rezoning of our campus in
West Harlem as you would imagine many of
the city council members stood up and
express their views why they were voting
the way they were voting no one talked
about 1968 that the university from
where I'm sitting psychologically has
made a big step from its past into its
future Joe Joe is executive vice
president of University facilities
arrived here 21 years ago and has a job
which includes everything from
conceiving of the facilities to making
sure they're built to building them to
cleaning them to demolishing them to
keeping them safe so it's really a
fairly comprehensive job how's the
university's changed since you arrived
21 years ago it's you know one thinking
back Robert it it almost feels like the
university's gone
from sort of this sepia color across the
campus having arrived in 1989 to this
multicolored you know that there's
there's real life and vibrancy here at
the University not that there was an
excitement in 1989 but it was a
different excitement than exists today I
think what clearly has happened over
that course of time and just very
quickly when I got here in 1989 it
became very apparent that women were
relatively new to the College for
instance and I think that the university
was still adjusting to that and it was a
time at which you know today when we
look at applications admissions and
financial aid and see one integrated
admissions and financial aid operation
for college and engineering that wasn't
the case then so there was a real sense
of everyone within the university having
to survive on its own bottom almost to
its disadvantage I think there is good
reason to do that for business reasons
financially and so on but with every
part of the institution competing
against itself I don't think that it
created a real strength at the center of
the university it was also a time where
columbia university in the city of New
York didn't have the same relevance it
was more Columbia University and the
city of New York was not necessarily an
asset and as the city became to get
stronger and the university has gotten
stronger over that time I think bridging
the two the university in the city has
created a very different relevance and
not to say that there isn't a sense of
competition amongst schools within the
university which is good but I think
that there is a clearer sense of purpose
from the center of the university a
clear a set of goals and objectives and
a reason for everybody to really work
together to make the whole stronger than
any one of its parts while we still
really maintain tremendous strength and
relevance in the core curriculum in
columbia college and the School of
Engineering and so on so we've sort of
moved into this multicolored you know
world of vibrancy and purpose
and I think have evolved a real core set
of strategic objectives instead of just
sort of getting through the you know the
the next minor crisis if you will